to me dresses about you know personality
you know speak I dress the way I am
that's I see like my studies of a class
because everything I tried to do is with
class
hey this is Serge Ibaka aka my food in a
Mufasa style mr. Burke class hundred
percent pure from the motherland this is
what you're wearing
okay one hour what I'm going
[Music]
my heart is a fuzzy chef you know it's
my foolish chef hat but you can see with
the logo and the sweater is a Carhartt
and then the sweatpants of white and
then my sneakers easy
Oh what I'm trying to get a dress I
always try to figure out you know when
wearing first from the toes then the
shirt or the jacket I'm gonna put on and
then from there we go with the pants and
then I'm gonna figure out if I need the
hat or no like today you can see I
already need any heart that's why I put
my fools hat I think for me you know the
most important thing part is the plane
for Vietnam so tall so to me that's most
important because is one of the hardest
thing for me you know even to find pants
can fit you perfect the way I want to
everyday style is depending the mood and
also it is depend on whether and where
I'm going from traveling like day like
today you know you see new way and this
one relaxing and when I'm going to the
game
I've different you know style I like to
go let's say if I have a game tomorrow
or I have an event tomorrow I'm gonna
prepare my outfit the 94 but even that
when I'm going to bed before you fall
asleep I'm starting already
if I have to change or try to keep the
same outfit this is Kendall and I like I
kind of like this outfit - it's kind of
you know you know some something you you
have to understand some time we were
things in Fashion Week because we want
to be good designer give you that and
you have the only that's the only option
you're where you know so you may
sometimes see me were from crazy outfit
or a PDF you like this color off you say
why search wearing that it's not my
choice right so I to go with what the
design give you an especially I'm so
tall it is very harmful for them to find
something my size you know so that's
what sometimes you see somehow feels
kind of even yeah I know a little off
but I to worry because it's fashion week
so you know the funny part is on this
picture our our the attack I didn't know
I'm going to sunix I'd you know that and
I feel like you know God happened for me
was my destiny
[Laughter]
well you know you know it's this what a
cult fashion you know you know fashion
why so this is what I call fashion is
about to express yourself with without
saying something
why if I see nothing but you already
explain yourself so in this picture you
can see from my face and I'm saying I'm
so telling you know I don't know exactly
I don't know why I did it when I'm
seeing this picture this is a bad friend
but the outfit look good or the outfit
is on fire you know when you come about
advice advice on in fashion it's kind of
hard because you know in Balga different
style you know different feelings with
fashion and the way they were close
also I keep telling people you know
fashion is not about wearing specific
things you know big logos style well
these were things make you comfortable
fashion is about here meant it you can
put outfit total outfit across 30,000 I
can wear something is called like
200-300 outfit the war here I feel like
I'm better than you
this is serge ibaka and this is what you
wearing check me out on a hungry are you
you're gonna have fun even enjoy we have
some of the best guests trust me you're
gonna miss this is my food is chef